we're going to talk about michael saylor
today
all right folks so today is a special
podcast we got a special guest for you
here today i would say this the first
time we got a billionaire in uh devault
michael saylor uh for some of you guys
that don't know his story i'll kind of
uh set him up and we'll get right into
it get your pens ready get your papers
ready get your mind ready it's about to
go for a workout the next two hours i
promise you and for some of you guys
that maybe still have doubts of
cryptocurrency or maybe even bitcoin
this man may change your mind here's why
mit grad he is the ceo and founder of
microstrategy nearly 2 000 employees
they started an 89 went public in 98
uh over 40 patents if you own one
bitcoin today a bitcoin as of right now
is worth forty four thousand five
hundred and twelve dollars
if you own ten that's 440 000
if you own 100 that's 4.4 million
dollars
but he owns personally
17
732 bitcoins and his company micro
strategy brace for impact owns
125 000 bitcoins let me say that one
more time 125 000 bitcoins so with that
being said michael saylor thank you so
much for being a guest on the podcast
happy to be here yeah so
here's the craziest thing about
what you were just talking about off
camera you just got into this
summer of 2020. it's not like you've
been a
true believer from day one it's not like
you bought in you know 12 years ago 10
years ago when these guys are talking
you just got in two years ago for a guy
as smart as you what made you switch and
say this is the way to go
um
you know most people don't think about
money
and we just kind of take it for granted
and and i uh really took it for granted
up until about 2020 but i think in march
of 2020 a lot of people's world's view
world views were shaken
right i had some deeply held beliefs you
know one belief is everybody should work
in an office and you had to come show up
and work in the office and then during
the lockdowns
i i found that i had to question that
belief and pretty soon we're all working
remotely and and i along with probably a
billion other people went through that
same transformation so that was like a
digital transformation of work
uh in uh in the second quarter of 2020
we had what we'll call a
k-shape recovery but in my opinion the
k-shape recovery was main street got
shut down and locked down and if you
manufactured anything or provided
services your business was wrecked
and then wall street had a rapid
miraculous recovery within six weeks of
the pandemic and they had the best year
of their life and
i could have basically
sat on a floatie in my you know poll in
the hamptons and got a 30 percent
in that year doing nothing
which would be the best year of my
entire business career if i'm a
financier
but if i was running a restaurant or
running a manufacturing facility or
doing something with raw materials
i would have had to generate 30 percent
more cash flow to get nothing
you would have and of course that was
impossible so can you explain can you
flint to the average get what that means
30 more cash flow
the value of the currency collapsed in
the year in essence the fed printed 40
of all the dollars in existence in the
18 months that followed the pandemic so
when jerome powell said we're not even
thinking about thinking about raising
interest rates you know and forecast
four years of zero percent interest
and when the fed loosened the reserve
restrictions on banks and allowed banks
to in essence print infinite money with
no reserve ratio
then uh the economy was flooded with
liquidity what happened was the stock
market immediately recovered people
thought that that was a that was
something good
it wasn't good it was the money
collapsing it was the value of the
dollar collapsing in real time against
scarce assets
so i most of the time if you owned a
portfolio of stocks if you had a billion
dollars worth of stocks and your
portfolio went up by 30 you would have
thought you were a genius in that year
for doing what for staying invested in
stocks why
because jerome powell printed 30 more
money
okay
if you didn't own a portfolio of stocks
if you thought you were going to work as
a dentist or a doctor or do things with
in the real world your business is shut
down the cost of all your materials is
going up your labor's disappeared and no
one is showing up to buy your stuff
the world doesn't look so good so you
had this uh
dichotomy i think and
the people on one side of of the economy
thought everything was just fine and
people on the other side the economy got
destroyed
i was sitting in the middle
i had a main street company that
generated 500 million in revenue and
generated cash flow
and uh i had a 500 million dollar
treasury that was sitting in
conservative instruments basically
invested in in short dated uh sovereign
debt you know the the conventional
strategy for any publicly traded company
is
you take your treasure and you buy one
to five-year t-bills
and otherwise you hold it in cash
now um
if the if the um
interest rates were three or four
percent and the money supply was
expanding at two percent you might think
that that was rational
when the interest rate goes to zero
percent and the money supply is
expanding at two or three percent it
looks a little bit painful
but when wall street recovers 30 percent
in a matter of weeks when main street's
completely shut down and it's pretty
obvious it's shut down
you're
you're uh
catalyzed to consider your premises
check your premises and ask the question
is the economy 30 better than it was
before the pandemic
or is there something else going on here
and i think the answer is there's
something else going on here the the
actual inflation rate isn't two percent
or zero percent the inflation rate was
30 percent but the inflation was hitting
the assets it wasn't hitting consumer
goods
and so
what i realized is maybe the money
supply is expanding faster than zero or
two percent a year and i started on a
search and i discovered the bitcoin
standard
and some austrian econ economists and
what i realized is the money supply had
really been expanding at seven to ten
percent a year for the last decade
that's why the s p indexes is
appreciating it ten percent a year for a
decade and once i realized that that
assets like the s p and equity
portfolios and real estate are driven
primarily by monetary policy of the
central banks
then i realized that holding money at
zero percent interest when the money
supply is expanding at 10 percent is
losing 10 percent of your wealth a year
and then i realized that in fact the
money supply was expanding not at 10 but
about 25 percent a year starting with
the
pandemic and i was going to lose half my
wealth on that treasury within 36 months
and once i realized that i was i was
destroying about 250 million dollars of
shareholder value if i did nothing
i started thinking i need to do
something
so in an environment where where the
money is losing
15 20 25 of its value a year and you're
sitting in all cash instruments
you either need to give the money back
to the shareholders or you need to
invest it in some scarce desirable asset
so
the reason i did what i did at
microstrategy was
if i gave the 500 million dollars back
to the shareholders
that was 60 a share the stock was 120 a
share
i basically was valued at one times
revenue plus the cash
when i gave the money back to the
shareholders the stock was going to go
to 60 a share when that happened
all my employees stock options were
going to be underwater
right
and
we were going to get beat to death
by amazon apple facebook and google
they're just going to steal all our
employees when the stock crashed and
that would mean that instead of growing
five or ten percent a year i was going
to be shrinking five or ten percent a
year instead of my cash flows doubling
or tripling they were going to be cut to
zero
and once your revenues start falling
your cash flows go to zero you have no
capital all your employees quit when
your employees quit the company unwinds
we're gonna go to zero
so giving the cash back to the
shareholders was a fast death
holding the cash at zero percent
interest when it was losing twenty
percent of its value a year as a slow
death
doing something was the alternative and
so
we decided to do something which is
invest the money in a property or in an
asset that would go up faster than the
rate at which the money was collapsing
and that set us on a search and we
considered buying a portfolio of scarce
art
i thought about 500 million worth of
real estate really you thought about
mine art yeah
i thought everything do you buy gold do
you buy art do you buy real estate do
you buy a portfolio of stocks do you
we're going through
perceptions before you settled on
bitcoin you were thinking art you're
thinking real estate you're thinking
anything other than
cash everything in fact in fact we put
out a press release to our entire
shareholder base when the stock's 120
and you can go read it today it said
over the next 12 months we're going to
buy back 250 million dollars worth of
our stock and we're going to invest 250
million dollars worth of our treasury
assets and some
some asset in order to avoid inflation
and we listed a litany of these things
and we included bitcoin as one of the
things we're evaluating
um ultimately so so we went from first
principles we said you have a bunch of
money
and i'll tell you why we said we're
going to buy back 250 million dollars of
our stock in a second uh but you have a
bunch of money say 250 million dollars
you want to hold it for a hundred years
give it to your great grandchildren
where do you invest it
well
if you put it into the dollar the dollar
is losing at least it's been losing
seven to ten percent of its value a year
for 100 years
that means over the course of 100 years
the dollar loses 99 of its value
my house in miami beach was purchased
for a hundred thousand dollars in 1930.
okay i bought it for 14 million dollars
this is the villa 2012.
today
you know yeah so
100 000 to 50 million
in less than 100 years that's
that's not the house getting more
valuable that's the currency getting
less value that means the 200 million
100 years from now there is nothing two
million bucks
okay if you took a if you took any
amount of money take a hundred million
dollars in the year nineteen hundred and
invested in any currency in the world
you would have lost
a hundred percent of your money in every
currency
except for the dollar or maybe the pound
every currency collapse the winner of
every war in the 20th century was the
united states
and so the winning currency loses 99.5
percent of its value everybody else you
lose everything
now if you if you put that money in gold
there's a 95 chance it would have been
seized
in the hundred years because there's
only a couple cities on earth maybe
zurich or geneva where you wouldn't have
had it stolen and maybe then they still
would have stole it you know if you were
the wrong citizen
in the wrong country if you were a swiss
citizen in switzerland for the hundred
years you might have kept gold
but uh you know churchill seized the
goal roosevelt seized the gold if you'd
lived in germany you would had your gold
seized multiple times in japan they lost
it two or three times and russia
you know count the number of times so
there's nowhere on earth where you could
have kept your uh your gold
and now you're stuck with okay well what
are you invested land
take um
take a hundred million dollars worth of
money and buy land in
florida tax bill's two million dollars a
year
if you buy property in florida's two
percent property tax a year it gets
assessed up every year you have the
ownership of the land for about 20 years
before the government takes it back from
you
you you don't own you don't own your uh
your property of the land yeah plus the
maintenance so
if you want to move money through time
how do you do it you can't do it with
the currency
the money is broken the money was always
broken it's been broken for a hundred
years losing seven to ten percent of its
value but
in hyper-inflating economies like
venezuela argentina
fill in the blank
the money uh loses 20 30 40 of its value
a year sometimes 80 of its value a year
in that case you can't even carry money
for a decade you might not be able to
hold money for a year in those economies
uh the russian rubles lost 35 percent of
its value in the past
few weeks
right that's how fast it collapses
so
fundamentally we have this issue i want
to move money through time i have it a
100 year time frame i'm an institution
the whole point of the institution's
supposed to go on right and so
how do you do it no currency will work
can you use gold
well gold is money is is the best idea
humanity had for like five thousand
years but it was but it's not a
perfected idea the problem with gold is
gold miners produce two percent more
gold a year
okay
that's no better than the state of
florida seizing two percent of your uh
your property a year in a property tax
the half-life of gold therefore becomes
about 30 years you divide two percent
into 70 in 35 years your money's cut in
half hold it for a hundred years it's
cut in half three times the second
problem is it'll be stolen by a criminal
or a politician that disagrees with you
and the third problem with it is that
gold is a property you have to put in a
vault and if you have to put in a vault
then the counterparty the bank is able
to hypothecate it and rehypothecate it
which means they basically sell
100 ounces of gold paper for every ounce
of gold you hold and they keep they keep
shorting it naked and they hold the
price down and manipulate the price
you can't hold your own gold
so
ultimately the problem with gold is
holding money in gold over the course of
a hundred years is going to lose 85 to
90 percent of your wealth under the best
of case
the other problem is
you can't move money through space
with gold i need to i need to move money
through time and space i need to hold it
for 100 years and i need to move it from
here to tokyo
if i want to move you know
a billion dollars of gold is like 30 000
pounds or something you want to move a
bunch of money through space it's gonna
cost you three to six months and five
million dollars to move it once
if you want to move it through time
you're going to lose 80 90 of your money
through time
and it's going to be seized so
gold's a pretty expensive way to move
money currency is an ineffective way to
move money
property property is only good so long
as the nation's state that the property
is in chooses to allow you to continue
to possess it
but of course the oldest you know the
oldest story in the world is oh we lost
the family farm because we couldn't pay
the property taxes
you can hold the price you can hold the
land
you know buy 10 000 acres of land
someone moves in and sets up shop next
to you they incorporate a city then they
bring 50 people in the city then they
make themselves mayor then they pro pass
a property tax then they annex your farm
then they give away free money to
anybody that wants free housing in the
city then they double your property tax
you can't pay your property tax then
they seize the property because you
can't pay the property tax so
ultimately property is not a very
effective way to hold money for a long
period of time and you can't move money
through space
so
this is a problem
i i started going down this rabbit hole
of thinking about what is money when i
realized that i was in essence going to
lose my company
right and destroy the livelihoods of all
my employees and you know waste 30 years
of my life and so when i started
thinking about it and you know it's
helpful when jerome powell says we're
not even thinking about thinking about
raising interest rates you know your
strategy of investing in bonds is broken
when i started thinking about it what i
realized is
money is energy
money is economic energy social
political energy currency is a medium
through which the energy moves
um
if if you wish to um if you wish to hold
energy and transport energy you need a
technology
we're not using gold anymore when we use
gold as i pointed out it's expensive and
it's uh and it's cumbersome
currencies don't work
the us dollar is the the strongest
currency in the world but is losing 15
to 20 percent of its value a year
the peso is losing 40 to 50 of its value
a year the boulevard is losing hundred
percent 95 98 of his value a year
so once you start thinking about it that
way you start thinking
well
what's a better way to store economic
energy through time and you realize that
the currencies don't work
gold doesn't work
so
what is money well money money in the
last 30 years became the s p index you
buy a diversified portfolio of companies
of stocks
which is a little bit better
because maybe you're getting bled two
percent a year by the management team
but the company's making money and so
maybe you can hold value
it turns out that the money is losing
about 10 percent of its value year and
the s p index is going up about 10 a
year and you look at that for a hundred
years and there's a very interesting
correlation there
a diversified portfolio of assets
is tracking the money supply
okay interesting
what's the problem with that
well the problem with holding stocks as
a store of value is if the stock goes up
by a factor of 10
there's a management team that has a
fiduciary obligation to issue more stock
there's a temptation to issue stock
stocks aren't scarce the the amount of
equity shares will also go up if the
stock is overvalued versus the
fundamentals of the company
the ceo is almost certainly going to
issue more stock
and so
that's one problem the second problem is
stocks have political nexus they have
management teams they're in countries
they can be unionized i can put a tariff
on the product i've got a competitor
what if the ceo goes bonkers
all sorts of interesting problems what
if the company gets expropriated by the
government you know or the jurisdiction
it operates within
stocks are an imperfect approach
better than gold
the other approach is by a bunch of
buildings in new york city by scarce
desirable real estate in miami los
angeles london
that's a an interesting idea and the
best idea in the 20th century if you're
going to if you're going to try to
either create
wealth or hold your wealth if you want
to hold your wealth
you buy a billion dollars worth of
property
if you want to create wealth you borrow
a billion dollars
and you buy a billion dollars of
property
and you start with a million dollars of
equity a sliver of equity and what
you're doing is you're going short the
currency and you're going along the
property
so if i told you
let's go to argentina
if i told you in argentina the peso is
going to go from one peso to the dollar
to five pesos to the dollar to 10 pesos
to the dollar to 20 pesos to the dollar
to 40 to 80 to 100
the black market rate right now is 210
pesos to the dollar
220. if i told you it was going to
collapse
from 1 to 20
and you had 20 years of notice
what's your best strategy
take your million pesos convert to
dollars and you're gonna have 220
million pesos in 20 years you're going
to look rich
better strategy
is borrow a million pesos convert to
dollars
wow best strategy would be mortgage your
entire company in pesos sell equity in
your company and pesos convert it all to
dollars
and then get the dollars out of the
country
because if they're in the country if
you're if the million
pesos is converted to dollars in a bank
in argentina then the government will
basically pass a law force your dollars
to be converted back into pesos devalue
them
and i happen to have some experience
with that because i actually had a
million dollars in argentina during the
last currency collapse they converted to
pesos they devalued it ten to one
a day later i'd lost 90 of my money
so
simple idea
short the currency which is collapsing
go long property and then get the
property out of the country
because the property in the country
is also going to devalue
because uh the property's value based
upon the extreme of cash flows right
if the building is uh has got a a rentor
and it's got a lease and the lease is
capped at cpi or or or denominated in
local currency when the currency
collapses the value of of the rental
income also collapses so
wouldn't it be great if i could buy a
virtual building
in argentina
using borrowed pesos
and then what if i could spirit the
building out of the country and rent it
to people in london or new york city
that's what bitcoin is
bitcoin is digital property
that you can teleport
anywhere in space instantly
and it's also perfected property with
with the lowest maintenance cost
you know you don't have the property tax
you have on a building you don't have to
repaint the thing every 10 years you
don't have to worry about leaks in the
roof
so if i could buy a big if i could buy a
billion dollars worth of property
and it was in cyberspace
and if you couldn't make any more of it
if i capped it at 21 million
city blocks in cyberspace
and if i could hold it for a thousand
years
i might have a better idea than buying a
city block in manhattan
or a building in london
or even a company
and it's a lot better idea than buying
30 000 pounds worth of gold
why
because real estate developers going to
create more buildings gold miners going
to create more gold mayors are going to
pass a property tax and they're going to
they're going to put some kind of
enjoinder or some kind of restriction on
your rents
rent control you're building
something you know acts of god are going
to create earthquakes and floods
and lightning strikes
and none of that stuff's happening in
cyberspace
so
the whole idea of bitcoin is
it's perfected engineered gold crypto
gold
with none of the none of the defects of
gold you can't mine any more of it it's
it's weightless i can move it at the
speed of light it never decomposes
i can deco i can i can break it into a
thousand pieces in a second
send it to a thousand places and
recompose it
uh all using a computer program
and i can take personal custody of it
maybe the most the most powerful two
ideas are
i can hold possession of a billion
dollars of bitcoin in my head
just holding a password or a set of
private keys that's a pretty big idea
maybe the first the first time in the
history of the human race that you can
actually take possession of your wealth
and take it to the grave with you or
take it anywhere else on earth with you
and even if i put a gun to your head the
most i can do is kill you
i can't take it
and this is a very interesting idea
every other form of property in the
history of the human race
i pull the gun i get it all
right my incentive is to violence with
bitcoin i pull the trigger i get none of
it
so
the incentive is the negotiation i'd
rather have half
than zero right and it's a very
interesting idea big idea
and the second big idea is got super
intimidated by the way
i'm
yeah i
the second big idea is it's a monitor
it's a virus
it's it's a cyber virus it's a it's a
chain reaction in cyberspace or it's a
life form in cyberspace
bitcoin is a bank in cyberspace run by
incorruptible software
and the software
the software itself is going to
basically protect your money
the problem with software is i don't
trust the computer it's on
if it's on a it's on a single phone i
can seize the phone and reprogram the
software so if i came up with the bank
and a bank that was run by software how
do i prevent any human being from
corrupting it
the thing that makes it incorruptible is
i release thousands tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of identical
copies in cyberspace and it's
self-replicating
and all of the copies keep track of each
other and when one of them is corrupted
it gets kicked off the network
so you could think of it as i released a
life form plankton
or a virus
and i let go
or a swarm
now you're a part of the swarm i shoot
you it doesn't help you have the genetic
code i shoot you doesn't help i
obliterate all of you know the the algae
in the atlantic won't stop it
i eliminate all of the bacteria in your
body won't stop it right it's a virus
it's gonna keep spreading
and
the beauty of the system is
it's in essence this chain reaction in
cyberspace and the only purpose of the
chain reaction is to protect the
integrity of the network
there will never be more than 21 million
bitcoin
so
what you've got
is
is truth
and integrity
released
as a as a cyber virus
and you can if you choose to join that
network
you avail yourself of all of the
benefits of that network how many of the
21 million bitcoin have been i've been
mined already
about 18 and a half million okay
yeah it's it's um i want to read you
something i want to read yourself
because i'm trying to see more the uh i
like the way you processed everything
with real estate with stocks
you know management teams ceo what could
happen to the market government can
regulate them etc and said okay fine
cash got it if you have 200 million
dollars you know two million dollars you
know 100 000 house in miami now it's a
50 million dollar house okay so maybe
that's also a risk because what florida
would do within 20 years but so here's
what just took place i'm trying to see
for somebody that's uh wanting to play
devil's advocate and be a skeptic
ukrainians
are preparing to lose internet access
okay this is crypto briefing
article per forbes in ukraine apps that
permit basic service like communication
and mapping without internet access are
tapping the downloads charts right now
such applications utilize radio signals
or bluetooth
uh for offline functionality and are
common with when civil conditions
deteriorate amid war government
crackdown the similar searches on uh
such downloads occurred in 2019 with
hong kong protests right while there has
been an influx of cryptocurrency
donations to the country amidst its uh
invasion cryptocurrency usage is
generally impossible without internet
connection parts of ukraine's third most
populous city odessa have already lost
power and forbes sources indicated their
expectation that ukraine could lose
power interconnected activity on a more
widespread basis this is where i'm going
with this so you know
kova takes place whatever you agree with
it there's a lot of different stories
it's a virus it came from this uh your
lab it came from this we don't know what
market is a lab we haven't done the
investigation we still don't know the
tribunal courts got to get out there and
say we got to do real investigation
but there was a community that says look
china is known for investing most of
their money in the military bio warfare
that's what their strength is at right
and russia is known for cyber warfare
that's where you know they got the
nuclear weapons we all know they're very
powerful with the nuclear weapons
but
we experienced what
you know if
we had a biowarfare the last 30 months
if we did we experienced a glimpse of it
what it did it shut down the entire
world right
what is your concern with a what a cyber
warfare would look like how would that
affect bitcoin and cryptocurrency
bitcoin is a nuclear hardened protocol
it's it's pretty much the most robust
resilient thing that human race has yet
to invent
for example
it's running uh on on
tens of thousands of nodes you can't
even identify the nodes and there's an
identical copy of the bitcoin ledger on
every one of them
so if all of the electricity got shut
off
everywhere on earth
and every computer failed everywhere on
earth
for 10 years
the protocol just goes dormant for 10
years and as soon as one person turns
one node back on the entire protocol
comes back to life again
there's nothing like that right
all your money in a bank and bank of
america could be wiped out with you know
a keystroke you go and you wipe out a
few servers you know your building can
be wiped out with a bomb right
lots of things can be wiped out but
but um
bitcoin is the most resilient thing in
cyberspace because it is so incredibly
decentralized you know if you took if
you took an entire country offline
that's irrelevant in fact we just saw
last year during the china crackdown
that china banned bitcoin mining
they took 40 to 50 of the entire network
offline half of bitcoin money was taking
place in china the network didn't miss a
beat
not even for a minute it just kept
running completely secure
you could literally wipe out 99
of all the nodes you wouldn't notice in
the network there's nothing else that
you rely upon if
i can take down google and twitter and
facebook and apple and amazon and the us
government and you know there's a lot of
other systems you can take down much
more easily you take down bitcoin
so
i don't really worry about uh about
bitcoin's
fragility to any cyber attack
in fact the whole point of proof of work
was to create something which is
impervious to a denial of service attack
and it turns out that if you dig a bit
deeper what you realize is that not only
is bitcoin impervious to cyber attacks
it's also the solution to cyber attacks
because
if you want to eliminate denial of
service attacks which are the most
common brute force attacks or you want
to eliminate phishing and scam and spam
uh attacks and and other sorts of
imposters and malicious behavior in
cyber space
the way to do it is to integrate a layer
of
monetary energy which is what bitcoin is
into the internet
you need to wrap
uh the avatars you need to wrap the
people the websites and the services
that we have in cyberspace with a layer
of digital energy if you did that you
could prevent all denial of service
attacks you could shut them down you
could probably shut down most of the
scam videos on youtube
all the scamming on twitter all the spam
in your inbox right the simple principle
is
you simply have to post a monetary
security deposit in order to hit my
website or message my inbox or post a
comment and if you're found to be
a scammer or a fisher or a malicious
actor you're fined and we just take your
money
now this is not a problem for an
ordinary person you would post ten
dollars once in your life and you will
trip through cyberspace as you will
but
1 000 times a week someone spends up a
michael saylor bitcoin giveaway on
youtube and those are live youtube class
they'll probably take this interview we
have they'll rip it out they'll put it
into a michael saylor bitcoin giveaway
they'll run it on youtube with 40 000
fake people listening
and they'll have some number where you
can where you can uh send bitcoin to get
send one to get two back
for those people listening i won't get
one scam never send your bitcoin to
someone to get two back you're getting
ripped off so they'll do that and they
will have spun up forty thousand fake
actors
if you actually required someone to post
ten dollars of bitcoin in order to trip
through youtube or use youtube it would
cost you
400 000
every 10 minutes because they get taken
down every 10 minutes and they get spun
up every 15 minutes it's literally
a thousand times a week and so imagine
trying to spend forty thousand or four
hundred thousand dollars a thousand
times a week to do this michael what
type of people fall for those scams i
mean you said you've been a victim of
you'd be using your your name for this
type of one out of a thousand
one in a thousand but yeah they
obviously work because they do them
every 15 minutes if you went online
right now and type michael sailor crypto
giveaway or something
i just bought a few before i got here
just kidding yeah
yeah so
bitcoin is it's digital energy right
this is a big idea we've encrypted
money right it's such a huge idea since
most people don't know what money is it
doesn't occur then that money is energy
since they don't understand what money
is they don't really understand that
money is defective
that the energy is bleeding out of their
currency and by the way
if
if money is energy the energy finds its
way into a currency it also finds its
way into into stocks and into bonds and
into
property they're all bleeding energy
over time or over space
and if you're an engineer
and you understand that a
well-engineered system is a system that
allows you to move energy through time
and space with no power loss no
impedance super conducting
which is
that we call that like uh you know it's
an adiabatic system or a
thermodynamically sound system
if you're an engineer you totally get it
when you're designing a pneumatic system
electrical system you know even a
heating system in a house or a swimming
pool
if the if the water drained out of your
swimming pool wouldn't work so well
right if your bathtub you know drained
out it was doesn't work so well
so engineers understand this but
economists don't really think of money
as energy and so they it doesn't occur
to them that the energy is bleeding out
of the systems
once you figure that out you realize
that bitcoin is truly brilliant because
what they've done
is they've created a thermodynamically
sound monetary network that allows you
to store any amount of energy
for any period of time
and move it at essentially no cost
anywhere in space as frequently as you
want
pat have you ever and it's lossless he's
saying lossless yeah that's a key word
you've heard that money is a tool money
enables i've never really heard money
being used as
energy is this something that you've
heard before where the energy thing
listen i mean it makes sense though he
it totally makes sense on what he's
saying the way he's describing it for me
uh if
when i'm listening to him speak all i'm
thinking about
and i hope the audience is doing this as
well as how this man processes issues
i mean as an investor everything he went
through
was common sense nothing that he went
through on how he came to
the processing of why he wants to do
this
is now you can sit there and disagree
and you can say i disagree with them i'm
gonna go this way i'm gonna go that way
which is totally fine but i'm just
listening to the way he's processing
issues tyler can you pull up that story
what happened with canada because for me
one of the things i'm watching michael
very closely right now is the following
all i watch is
you know i got four kids i watch the
kids on how they handle a crisis
i watch kids how they handle a loss
i watch kids how they handle a you know
a breakup how they handle a
rejection how they handle a bullying how
they handle all this because that's how
we're learning about the personality of
the individual and maybe there's an
opportunity there to coach
and walk the kid through what he's going
through
i also watch what's going on with crisis
how the market reacts to crisis you said
a few different things you said
you know what kova did to me is it made
me
question a few things one of them was
working remotely it's one of the things
you talked about right the other one was
you know this and this and that some of
the things that you know i was looking
at was
number one we've been told you know when
i went and started working on morgan
stanley dean with a day before 9 11 even
when i was in the army everybody would
say buy a roth ira diversify okay
diversification
that's a concept we've heard for a long
time
uh inflation increases gold whenever
there's inflation peter's shift oh my
gosh gold's gonna go because you know we
printed 40
percent of the us dollar has been
printed the last 18 months gold's going
to go up we didn't see that cause and
effect you know we didn't see the cause
and effect with that taking place
uh you know what are your thoughts with
some of these things where the
traditional conventional way of things
have been questioned based on the last
18 24 months inflation and you know
inflation and diversification are both
bromides there there are these uh
simplistic terms that people toss around
but no one really thinks very deeply
about them in my experience i mean let's
start with inflation um
inflation is not two percent inflation
is not the cpi
it's not seven and a half percent
inflation uh properly understood is
simply the rate at which the price of
anything appreciates in the currency
which is the frame of reference which
means that you can calculate an
inflation rate for a picasso painting
which is different than a building in
new york which is different than a bond
which is different than
a market basket of of goods and services
that you wish to buy which is different
than the market basket of goods and
services i want to sell you
so what's the real inflation rate it's a
vector
right it's not a scalar a scalar is like
two percent no it's not it's like an
n-dimensional vector and there's a
different inflation rate for everything
in every place
for every time period dynamically
evolving right
once you understand that you realize
that
there's probably two inflation rates of
interest one inflation rate is the rate
at which uh cost of living is going up
for a middle-class family
that's not the cpi because the cpi is a
manipulated market basket
set by uh a politician or a bureaucrat
that's
that is uh
engineered not to go up in price very
fast
most average people would find that
their inflation rate is higher than the
cpi
and if you know for example we don't
include the cost of buying a home in the
cpi even though it sounds the reason
that just about any reasonable person
would want to buy a house at some point
in their life
so you can calculate a consumer
inflation rate which is different than
cpi but you can also calculate an asset
inflation rate that's the rate of that's
the cost of getting rich or staying rich
if you want to be wealthy
it's not good enough to keep up with cpi
you have to actually keep up with the
rate at which assets are appreciating
right um
the cost of housing went up eighteen
point eight percent year over year this
is case schiller according to case
schiller index right
that's another uh that's that's a common
asset but if you look at um the s p
index which is a market basket of
desirable companies that gives you a
surrogate for a monetary inflation rate
the monetary inflation rates been
running seven to ten percent a year in
the us at the same time that the cpi has
been running one percent
if you understood that you understand
that your cost of capital is more like
10 which meant that any investment you
made that didn't yield 10 was making you
poorer you were losing wealth you were
you know any business person understands
that i couldn't get you to accept a two
percent roi on an investment
so
if you if you understand inflation's a
vector
then then you start to realize that the
inflation rate in miami beach is
different than it is in kansas city
and you understand that the inflation
rate if you want to stay wealthy is much
higher the inflation rate in 2020 was
about 25 percent
for assets
the inflation rate
for bonds was was at one point higher
right you could have bought a bond for a
million dollars that yielded fifty
thousand dollars in interest a decade
ago if you wanted social security if you
wanted fifty thousand dollars in income
risk-free the rest of your life the cost
was a million dollars
when the 10-year yield went to 50 basis
points
you would have to pay 10 million dollars
for the same bond
the bond went up by a factor of 10.
what's the inflation rate
right the inflation rate in that
particular case was a hundred percent it
was like hyperinflation
you had hyper inflation in the bond
market you had infl massive inflation in
the asset market you had no inflation in
the domino's pizza delivery you know
netflix market for a while
and uh and if what you want to do is
live in your parents basement and watch
netflix and order pizza
then the inflation rate
much much lower for you
and uh if you wanted to if you wanted to
stay wealthy or you wanted to get
wealthy or hold shareholder value
inflation rate looks more like 30 40
percent in like 18 months
so once you understand inflation is a
vector then you stop paying attention to
just one cherry picked number
because what you realize is i can
manufacture
any inflation rate you want simply by
adjusting the market basket of products
and services and
by definition
by definition if i never include assets
in the market basket of desirable goods
then you will always
ignore asset inflation which is the most
pernicious inflation
so we have had hyperinflation since 1971
but the inflation has manifested itself
in the assets
and the pr here's the pernicious thing
about it
i've literally brainwashed you into
thinking that asset inflation isn't a
bad thing it's a good thing and it isn't
inflation at all
it's actually investment gain right so
so that's
when
when i convince you that a bad thing is
a good thing
right we've we've come to a a bizarre
point so
we're living in inflation since we went
off the gold standard it's just in
manifesting the assets we have
hyperinflation right now it's just
manifesting itself in the assets more so
than in the goods and services
now if you go to diversification it's
another bromide another silliness you
should be diversified lots of people say
that a lot of times the people that say
that to you want you to give them your
money
right it's like i'm a hedge fund manager
and so i'm going to stand up and tell
you you need a broadly diversified
portfolio of like international equities
and domestic equities and like some of
these commodities and it changes all the
time it's very complicated it's too
complicated for you to figure out so you
just give me your money i'm going to
charge you a two percent fee keep 20
percent of the upside and i'm going to
invest it in this hyper complicated
array diversification of stuff
right
i'll give you a simple idea go buy
bitcoin
don't give me anything i don't want your
money i don't want the two percent i
don't want 20 of the upside
and bitcoin is a diversified index
of the entire world economy and
certainly the crypto economy as it comes
to its senses
you can believe one thing or the other
thing
you can imagine if you're in the
business of managing people's money the
last thing you want to do is tell them
the answer is just buy this one thing
and hold it for 100 years how do i make
money off of that
right
on the other hand what's the problem
with diversification
well uh first of all the problem with
diversification is diversification is
selling the winner to buy the losers
and the second problem with
diversification is
you're not really diversified at all
because everything you own is probably
correlated to one currency which is
collapsing so let's let's deal with them
one at a time
if you own apple stock in the year 2010
a mutual fund manager or a hedge fund
manager would tell you he's going to
diversify you because when apple stock
doubles he's going to sell some of that
so he can buy some hp or some dell or
some other ibm or some other computer
company and when apple doubles again
he's going to sell some more to keep you
diversified in the computer sector
because he wouldn't want you out of too
much exposure to apple
the problem with that is that at one
point apple
became 150
of all the profit in the entire mobile
phone industry
that is to say the winner eats everybody
not only does it eat everybody
everyone competing against apple is
losing money to compete against apple
so you're selling the winner
to buy the losers you're going to sell
facebook to buy the newspapers you're
going to sell
google so that you can buy every every
company competing against google you're
going to sell amazon to buy the other
retailers amazon won
walmart almost kept up
15 000 retailers lost
right and why is that
well
it's it should be pretty obvious why it
is right now
when you have a dominant digital
monopoly the digital monopoly eats
everything else and apple computer is
the most valuable company in the world
because apple computer is literally
the most valuable company in the world
they can ship a product to a billion
people over the weekend for a nickel
and their competitors can't
so selling the winner
to buy the loser
is an awful strategy the only people
that made money in the stock market in
the last decade were the people that
that owned fang they owned apple amazon
facebook google microsoft
there's no diversification here at all
so if you're if you're if you're
investing
in a stable currency
you have to keep in mind that digital
monopolies uh are dominant and they
crush everything else then and
everything else goes to zero so the only
everything else goes to zero
name another retailer you'd rather own
than amazon
so you're saying ethereum's gonna go to
zero what i'm saying is that ethereum's
a different subject we can talk about it
in a bit what i'm saying is
if you're a conventional investor the
winners tend to crush the losers by far
and so diversification of selling the
winner to buy the losers is not a good
idea
of you know eventually all you know what
what portion of the s p return is
attributable to five companies out of
the 500.
it's like 80 or something ridiculous
like that right
so
now here's the other problem
i'm gonna put you in venezuela
okay so you're in venezuela and you have
a choice you can buy one company in
venezuela or the entire index of
venezuelan stocks or you can buy one
building in venezuela or all the
buildings in venezuela or you can buy
one bond in venezuela or all the
venezuelan bonds
give me a diversification strategy which
is going to actually keep you from
losing all your money over five years if
you're sitting in venezuela five years
ago what is it
they're all correlated you see it's like
you're on you're shuffling deck chairs
on you know on the titanic the ship is
sinking
you're shuffling these deck chairs the
fundamental elephant in the room here is
when the currency collapses right give
me a diversification strategy for
russian stocks right now which of those
do you want to own
when the currency collapses
the bonds collapse that are that are
linked to the currency
all the companies that generate cash
flows and the currency they all collapse
because they're valued as a stream of
cash flows and if the cash is worthless
how is the company going to be valuable
right you sell beef in argentina the
peso collapses the people are buying the
beef and pesos so you want to sell the
beef to europeans for euros the
government passes a law keeping you from
selling the beef or exporting your beef
export controls come wage and price
controls come
so the problem is every equity
every piece of debt every piece of
property linked to the currency is
correlated to the currency
so your diversification strategy with
any given currency whether it's the peso
the dollar the euro the ruble
the lira the whatever they're all
correlated so then you're like okay well
this is great i'm just gonna buy the
dollar
all the currencies are correlated to the
dollar and the dollar is collapsing
how fast is the dollar collapsing
well you can you can watch it against
real estate in miami beach
right you know you can walk all you got
to do is look at the at the dollar
versus any scarce desirable piece of
property so what's the dollar valued in
versus a picasso a leonardo da vinci a
city block in new york city a desirable
piece of bench beachfront property and
how about palm beach right what's
happened to palm beach property in the
past 10 years
so ultimately the problem with
diversification is
nearly everything every stock is
correlated and and every every
conventional asset is generally
correlated the only true diversification
is if you find
non-sovereign stores of value
stores of value that have val that
derive their value based upon something
other than the cash flows
that you could derive from them
right so
you know think hard about what those are
real pristine trophy properties
might protect you
but i think um
i think that the problem ultimately is
is
if you're on a sinking ship
you have to get off the ship
and the problem with diversification
like when you're in the retail industry
and when it's completely getting
obliterated by amazon
you have to get off you have to get out
there's no winning strategy no matter
how you diversify in
and so
most of the time these models inflation
is two percent or cpi and you know we
should stay diversified they're based
upon this very conventional wisdom that
i live in this safe world and nothing
has changed
like there is no
when godzilla shows up to the playground
the rules of the game change
right
if there's an external factor
right you have this model it's like it's
always been like this it's always traded
like this in the last 30 years
well the u.s dollar never collapsed in
the past 30 years the u.s dollar is
losing 7 percent of its value for 30
years so your model says buy property
and buy the s p index
what happens when the us dollar is
losing 21 percent of its value
right it's like that's a different thing
[Music]
and i i think that
if we come back to energy
energy is life
and and if i suck the energy out of this
room i freeze you to death right when i
when i suck the energy out the
temperature keeps falling if the
temperature is falling one two percent
you can crank it up and try to deal with
it but when the temperature is falling
ten percent
at some point you'll start to freeze if
i if i pull enough energy out of the
room fast enough and at that point you
have to entertain a new notion an oxygen
mask
you know put on a coat you got to exit
the room eventually
and
if we come back to this issue right the
issue of the day is ukraine but what's
really going on here
the currency in the banking systems have
collapsed in afghanistan
in iraq
they're falling and collapsing in turkey
they've collapsed in lebanon
in syria they're not trustworthy
in ukraine and in russia
now i've just lassoed about 400 million
people
and those 400 million people don't have
a currency that they can use as a medium
of exchange or a store of value they
don't have banks that they trust that
work effectively
and
what's the fundamental issue here it's
like if you don't have a property or a
currency with which you can store
economic energy that's like being a type
one diabetic you cannot store fat on
your body it means that you can eat as
much as you want you will literally
starve to death
right because you don't have the ability
to store energy fat is organic energy
just like property is uh is a
manifestation of energy
in low frequency
i give you a billion dollars in the
currency it's high frequency money i
give i buy a billion dollar building i
hold it for 30 years it's low frequency
money
right either way
okay i give you a billion dollars you
buy a building in in some central
african republic someone puts a gun to
your head takes your building now you
have no building
you buy a billion dollars with the
currency the currency collapses because
the guy that runs the country prints
more of it it goes to zero
you know like uh
paper money in venezuela is not as
valuable as toilet paper right now
what is it right not not clear so
what you have is an economic collapse
and
it's a global phenomenon today and it
was accelerated in march of 2020
right the catalytic event the catalyst
for these things normally is a war
a war on covid
a war on currency
a war on a lot of things we're fighting
a lot of wars right now and now we've
got real wars right a political and
actual war in ukraine
wars collapse currencies they always
have world war one collapsed the
currency world war ii also damaged the
currency you can actually trace it if
you look at real estate values in the
years that follow the war
right so
what we're doing is we're collapsing the
currency and you could describe the
entire world right now as 8 billion
people
there's one strongest currency the
dollar which is losing 15 to 20 percent
of its value a year
that's how fast it's bleeding out you've
got to set you've got a set of tier of
currencies pegged to the dollar
sing you know singapore the middle east
the euro that are fairly uh fairly close
to the dollar then you've got a set of
second-tier currencies the peso and and
the the turkish lira and the like and
they're losing 40 percent the the ruble
now losing 40 50 of their value a year
and you get the third tier currencies
the venezuelan you know the boulevard
etc they pretty much hyperinflate they
all collapse and they're all going to
dollarize
this this trend is going to continue
crypto falls into this trend because
what's happening is people realize
they can't trust their local currency
they can't trust their local bank
if you don't trust the bank why don't
you trust the bank and canada right the
bank might seize my assets if they
disagree with me
in afghanistan the banks all failed you
know when the u.s pulled out and lebanon
the banks basically closed froze
everybody's assets
seized and converted all their foreign
currency assets into local lebanese
money devalued the money and they locked
it up for 10 years
okay so when you have
hundreds of millions if not billions of
people losing faith in the currency
losing faith in the banks what do you do
you look for the digital solution and
the digital solution is i download a
mobile app to my phone
and then i convert whatever asset or
work or property i have into a
cryptocurrency
and there's two things that i really
want badly
one thing i want badly is crypto dollars
like tether or circle or the like it's
basically u.s dollars sitting on crypto
rates stable coin stable coin
and the world's bought 190 180 190
billion of that from like 5 billion over
the past 24 months it's exploding
it will go to 10 trillion
if they could right the market has a
trillion to 10 trillion dollar demand
for that stable coin
what will happen when that happens
every one of these local weak currencies
collapses
right there's not a single currency in
africa in south america in asia you
would rather hold than the dollar right
now the chinese don't want to hold the
cny they would all convert to the us
dollar how do you know that because
their capital controls every country
that implements a capital control making
it illegal to convert their currency or
move their capital out of the country is
signaling to you that their currency is
weak and that includes the chinese
currency
so that's one dynamic you got 130
currencies floating in the world there's
probably only two or three that will be
left when the dust settles you got the
euro the cny the usd
everything else either gets pegged to
those or it collapses into those
and then the second thing the world
wants is once crypto property it wants
money to give to your grandchildren i i
want to hold my money for a hundred
years if not a thousand years
the dollar won't work
the dollar is losing two percent of its
value a month
which is horrific
and you know horrific over 36 months
it's catastrophic over 10 years
and people are getting smart enough to
realize that that won't work
so the issue is
where do i put my long-term money i need
a savings account
so hence this is where bitcoin comes in
bitcoin is the dominant crypto property
network in the world it's it's pretty
much the only
the only perfected
digital property network the human race
has created it's it's a proven digital
property
everything else is a speculation that it
may become property over time bitcoin is
the success and every like-kind
competitive bitcoin has collapsed
against it such that bitcoin is the 95
dominant network in this space
the dollar is clearly the dominant the
dominant currency and it wants to be the
dominant digital currency it is really
the dominant digital currency as well
despite
despite the fact that the us government
doesn't have you know us banks issuing
them yet we've been slow on the uptake
you can see where this is headed
and the driver is the stampede of
everybody else in the world right you
know you're a rich american and you feel
comfortable with your banking structure
okay maybe you can ignore this but name
somebody in africa asia or south america
that can ignore this issue right now
right i mean i invite you to sell all
your money and move to a country in
africa and then invest it in local local
property local companies
local currencies and put in a local bank
and feel good about yourself you've
mentioned
south america latin america multiple
times venezuela you must have some
strong feelings on what's going on in el
salvador
with naive buchelli the president of el
salvador is that someone
you follow or you're in touch with or
anything like that the situation in el
salvador is uh
is
instructive
because el salvador
doesn't have their own currency
they had a war a civil war and following
the civil war their currency collapsed
and so they dollarized
so the medium of exchange in el salvador
has been the dollar
and so
their problem is and and
and was
that uh the banking system the us
banking or the traditional 20th century
banking system is too expensive and
cumbersome to serve the people of el
salvador
over 100 years they managed to put two
and a half million people into a banking
relationship
over three weeks they rolled a digital
asset than they accomplished in 300
years
and now i can put up one tower and give
internet access to millions and millions
of people
for 1 1000th
of the cost of doing it with the copper
line
technique
so if you think about digital banking
the future of the world is eight billion
people with mobile phones
i download an application in 60 seconds
and on that mobile phone i carry a
digital currency like the dollar
maybe the euro
maybe a local maybe the yen or the one
maybe if there's an effective nation
state
if there's not an effective nation state
i just clearly swap out to the dollar
immediately everybody would want to do
that
and then i also carry a digital property
bitcoin
i want to hold it for 100 years it's a
you know instead of holding a building
which you can you can tax or seize or
rain on
or instead of like holding a bar of gold
which you can take from me i'm just
gonna hold my digital bar of gold on my
phone and then maybe i have some other
assets maybe i have digital art maybe i
have digital securities you know maybe
copies of uh ownership of something else
that i might like sitting in a wallet
but certainly
this i can give to everybody on earth
and i can move the money at the speed of
light
and what do i trust i'm trusting a piece
of software
which is
which is a lot cheaper and a lot more
reliable
than trusting a building a bank a board
of directors a man
when you actually have your money in
this bank vault i mean look at it
imagine money in the
think about that when you had your money
there you were trusting the guy that ran
the bank the manager the bank the mayor
the head of the police force of the bank
the head of security of the bank the
dude that came to actually fix the lock
everyone that touched the thing the
governor of the state then you're
trusting the head of the country the
central bank that managed the country
the military system who do you trust
with bitcoin
nobody
that's the point
nobody bitcoin's a bank in cyberspace
run by software incorruptable software
and this is
this is the beauty right really great
engineering it takes an a corruptable
element
and puts corruptable or imperfect
elements together in a system such that
they cancel out their imperfections to
create perfection
where did this happen happens in a
thermostat
in a thermostat i you know i have um i
have a strata or a metal and the metal
contracts
when it gets cold and expands when it
gets hot
okay now i tell you build something
which doesn't contract and expand when
it gets cold and it gets hot you're an
engineer how do you do it
you take the you take the piece of metal
that's going to contract and you put it
in opposition to another piece of metal
that contracts the other way but if
they're both the same and they both
contract with the same force
and you pin them they cancel each other
out
and then you actually get a zero
tolerance perfect machine
that's how john harrison created a
perfected clock he basically used that
insight that imperfect elements can
create a perfect mechanism and a clock
that clock was used to calculate
longitude on the ocean
that's how we actually navigated for 300
years it it's all based upon a bunch of
imperfect elements that create a perfect
mechanism bitcoin is the same thing
i've got a piece of software it runs on
a machine is it perfect no why because
you can corrupt it
how do i fix it i give another piece of
software
to him
now the two of each of your machines
check each other
well what if you're both corrupted well
i throw another 10 000 of those pieces
of software into the ether well who do i
give them to people i don't know
how do i corrupt them how do we find
them
okay what if i promised a murder
everybody in the u.s that doesn't change
their bitcoin nodes doesn't help
doesn't help what if i murder everybody
i can find with a bitcoin node doesn't
help i can't right
how do you stop a fire
how do you stop a fire in cyberspace
right it's like you've released this
thing you've operated you've invested
you've seen things you saw amazon drop i
don't know what was it 95 percent in 05
whatever the year was when the stock
went down 95 percent i may be wrong on
the year
you've seen a lot okay you've seen a lot
what's happening yeah so
you seem
a hundred percent certain about what
you're talking about which his history
doesn't favor a hundred percent
certainty
you know it it typically you know
and it's not even the i'm not even
talking about the trust but verify
there's got to be an element of
skepticism but you're like no you it's
almost a combination of a
uh a person who has experience running a
business investor
genius but also a salesperson you're
very very good at persuading as well
are you
a hundred percent certain about
the future of bitcoin and that it it has
zero risk there's no risk that could be
anything i don't think you can state
that no i think that everything in life
has risk
so there's a there's a black swan risk
an unknown unknown and anybody
intellectually honest has to admit that
there is that risk
that's not what i would say what i would
say is
you have to you've got a a bucket of
money
let's come back to africa okay
you've got a you've got a hundred
thousand dollars in africa you've got
invested in something you've got to put
it into a building and to land into an
african currency into something else
what are you gonna do
there is a hundred percent certainty
that you're going to lose 80 percent of
your money in most currencies over the
next decade
there's 100 there's 100 certainty you're
going to lose 95 percent of your wealth
over 30 years in just about every
currency and and so
you have to work through each of these
issues and say
what's the cost of doing nothing what's
the cost of not taking a risk what's the
risk-free rate
well i mean the risk-free rate is the
monetary inflation rate
so the price that you pay to not do
something is the rate at which the money
is collapsing if you were russian
they just lost 35 of their wealth by not
doing anything in the matter of weeks so
so in this particular case you just have
to look at the array of options
if uh if you're an investor in uh
south america or asia or africa i would
say
the the risk-free rate is much higher
for you right the ins
like you're in lebanon
what are you gonna do in lebanon how
about afghanistan how about iraq right
what are you gonna do
um in all those situations
they're thinking maybe i'll trust my
money to tether you know tether is run
by bitfinex it's just a company
so why is it that people in many
countries are more willing to uh
trust a company out of hong kong that's
running a stable coin on the crypto
network then they're willing to trust
their local bank
well because in fact tether is probably
a better bet than than betting your
money on
most currencies in the world other than
the top 12 currencies the rest are
collapsing why do tether if you can just
do the us dollar or usdc well you can't
that's the point
why do why do tether if you could just
do the us dollar okay how many people in
africa can walk into a bank of america
in new york city open an account and
then get the us dollar none of them
that's the whole point
right and okay i did it i'll give you an
example
i put a million dollars into bank of
america in argentina
when the dollar was worth one peso
because i didn't trust the peso i did it
what do you think happened
the government basically shut down for
one day
they sent an edict to the bank saying
all dollars must be converted back into
pesos
then they went off the dollar peg and
they divided the peso ten to one
and i lost ninety percent of my money
okay
so why do tether instead of trust bank
of america in argentina
you tell me
right because what's the odds that
tether is going to go to zero
in the next year
if the odds were 90 your money is going
to zero in the next year by putting it
somewhere else then you would think
maybe that's a risk i want to take
so
you know
people are forced out the risk curve
based upon the monetary policy and in a
hyper-inflating economy in zimbabwe
right you're going to take everything
you've got you're going to buy anything
i don't know if you if you saw um
you'll buy toilet paper you'll buy boxes
of cereal right
you'll buy anything uh there's pictures
in turkey
people and this is this year people go
into uh they go into a car lot and they
buy all the cars
okay so here's here's the news story
the government in pounds 54 cars that
were bought by a hoarder
someone had the temerity to actually
convert their currency into automobiles
because they thought the automobiles
would hold their value better than the
currency and then the government seizes
their automobiles
okay if you look at every single war
right the the war always has the story
of the speculators right the speculators
the scot the the smugglers and the
hoarders
what's your crime
your crime was not holding your money in
the currency which was losing 90 percent
of its value but rather deciding to buy
too many automobiles now your crime was
hedging
something like that picking at picking
an alternative asset as a storehouse of
what you perceive to be security until
the sovereign comes back and does one of
two things that they're good at
sovereigns know that debt
long term there's the jubilee theory and
also inflate your way out this is or
seize and force conversion which
basically feeds right back into inflate
your way out
eventually that
yeah that all these countries will just
inflate their way out and the currencies
collapse and that's why they're all
collapsing
right that the currencies are weaker
today
than ever what
i i and i think that's pretty obvious
the dollar will also be printed to pay
off the debt and
that will just manifest itself and the
dollar continuing to lose value against
scarce assets
it will gain value it'll be stronger
than the other currencies because
they're just collapsing faster so
eventually we'll see a world where
there's a dollar in the cny
right if you're not a very powerful
empire you can't maintain your currency
and uh that'll be the medium of exchange
and everything will be pegged to it or
correlated to it and then you're going
to see
monetary energy flowing out of weak
property and weak assets into strong
property
like
like i would sell all the land i have in
africa and convert to bitcoin but i
would sell all the land in africa and i
would move it to europe and i'd probably
sell my land in europe move to the u.s
and i'd sell my land in the u.s and move
it to bitcoin you're just swapping
from a weaker thing to a stronger thing
and the definition of weak is a function
of what's the risk it'll be seized taxed
or impaired
right regulated right so
calculate that right will the government
the jurisdiction that your property's
nbc's confiscated taxed away
impaired away and the last the last
issue is we'll be inflated away
right the reason that bitcoin is magical
is because there's only 21 million
um i can create more real estate in new
york city
i can create more cars i can create more
luxury watches i can print i can create
more gold i can create more shares of
stock i can create more bonds
i can create any commodity their
commodities by definition given enough
money and time i can create infinite of
any of them
bitcoin is a scarcity
okay name another scarcity
in the world right and technically it's
not clear there is another scarcity
right a scarcity is something of which
it is absolutely capped if the price
goes up by a factor of a thousand or a
million it is absolutely capped
that is not the case with gold soybeans
silver stock bonds real estate single
family homes ships planes trains
nothing else
everything else could be manufactured
and of course
if the price goes up the the the
incentive to manufacture more will go up
which is why
you know buying a house isn't
necessarily going to be a great store of
value in an inflating economy because
you're going to have incentives for
someone else to dilute the value of your
house if you do buy a house
better off to buy a house on land than a
condo on the 57th floor of a building
and if you do buy it on land better off
to buy it on
on waterfront property
and and if you buy water from property
better off to buy it on the beach
and if you buy it on the beach you're
better off to buy it in the in the most
desirable
location of affluent intelligent people
for the next 30 years sure pat has
scarce pristine which you
you're better to be at scarce pristine
or as close as you can and that's that
and you can do that for 10 20 30 years
that's palm beach that's the hamptons
right you can figure that out now figure
it out for a hundred years
that's this is the problem right when
you go out for the individual though who
cares for 100 years the individual how
many individuals think 100 years though
michael institutions think institutions
do but how many even some institutional
leaders only care about the return
they're going to give you for a decade
or two they don't sit there and or next
think about a hundred years i think
here's the point i mean that's that's
one of the problems we have with our
current uh uh political system even we
have in america you know the the guy who
gets elected he only cares about two
terms how much can he really do it's
tough the issue is the assets reflexive
if if i told you that that uh you could
buy this digital asset and it would lose
its all of its value in 17 years
then people start to amortize it down
and when it gets to be 12 years old
people start to discount it it's like
you don't want to own a building in
london where there's a ground lease that
expires in 37 years
right that's not as valuable as owning
the land outright for a thousand years
so if i told you it's good for 10 years
i think and the other thing is good for
a hundred years everybody wants the
thing that's timeless
and the difference is going to create a
marginal difference in the price let's
say it's two percent or three percent
okay so all the intelligent money go
they stamped in the thing that's two
percent better
and when they stamp anything that's two
percent better liquidity is 10x more and
then the money collapses out of the
other thing and it it goes to zero
that's why bitcoin cash collapses
bitcoin satoshi vision collapses
anything that's sort of like the same
thing but not quite as good
will go to zero that's why youtube is
youtube right it's like there there is a
tendency
of winner take all in these things
and uh and it it does matter
right now
you have children you have grandchildren
right i i never met anybody that said
you know i just i kind of want to keep
my family generational wealth intact for
12 years but then i don't care anymore
right you sort of care
and and and there's one more element to
this
it's it's not just the ability to know
that the asset will hold value 100 years
out it's the portability
you know if you're living in uh you're
living in nazi germany in 1932
having portable property versus
non-portable property makes a difference
might make a life or debt there are
people that are dead
because they couldn't move the property
right it does make a difference to be
able to move it
so you can't you can't blink your eyes
and teleport a billion dollars of real
estate in los angeles somewhere else in
the world you can't even move it
somewhere else in the country
being able to move the money
from a city to another city from a state
to a state
from a country to a country and from a
counterparty to a different counterparty
all of these things are are
extraordinarily valuable the difference
in life and death
in many cases
and and that's what bitcoin gives you
that you don't get
with anything else well you i i brought
up ethereum uh earlier you said we can
cover that as well you know there's a
lot of guys that are pro ethereum and
you know they swear by now if nft you
know most of the purchase 50 is being
done by ethereum ethereum's eventually
going to get a better than bitcoin or
you know ethereum's going to be right
there next to bitcoin what are your
thoughts on the theory
so first of all
if you look at the crypto ecosystem
there's crypto property there's crypto
currencies there's crypto platforms and
there's crypto securities and there's
even crypto art
right these are just asset classes maybe
they'll be crypto commodities
nft is crypto art it's like art
cryptographically protected
uh stablecoin is cryptocurrency a dollar
or a euro moving on crypto rail it's
currency because i can move it as a
medium exchange without paying a tax
bill on it
um
ethereum's crypto platform right people
are building other things on that
platform and and that's
the principal appeal smart contracts and
and the fact that you can build
something
bitcoin is crypto property it is a
long-term store of value
and um
and it is the dominant crypto property
and the way it establishes itself as
crypto property
is through nakamoto consensus and proof
of work you you have a decentralized
mining network that is encrypting energy
with the sha-256 hash function in order
to create
this wall of encrypted energy and and
make it uh resistant to denial of
service attacks other sorts of attacks
it needs to be robust
and have integrity over
over time and space and that's the
that's the technique that we've
developed now here's the big idea an
important idea most people don't
understand securities law
okay bitcoin's the only
proven
digital property
that we have created in the world we
have we have created a property and not
a security
the definition of property is um is a a
common commodity that is beyond the
control of any one individual or
corporation
if something is deemed property uh in in
a legal sense it means it wouldn't be
regulated by as a security by the sec
um gold is property
soybeans are property wood lumber land
is property bitcoin is property
okay um did the sec come out and
officially state that that it's not it's
not a securities it's officially a
property it's understood that that
bitcoin is not regulated by the sec
bitcoin is property it's the only thing
we all agree on in the crypto
marketplace
that bitcoin is property
um
securities are regulated by the sec and
you can you can create a security
uh microstrategy mstr is a security
go read my 10k statement it's 123
pages of disclosures that are legally
required for that stock to trade that
security to trade
it cost 20 million dollars a year for us
to maintain all the disclosures to be
compliant with securities law if you're
a security it's a different thing
bitcoin is property
ethereum
everything else in the crypto ecosystem
likely they're all securities right why
are they securities
they're controlled by
groups of developers they're issued
pursuant to icos initial coin offerings
that makes them security
if there's a pre mine and there was a
group of of individuals that initially
control the thing it makes it security
if um you know if anyone can exercise
undo influence it comes to security and
technically if you know if you look at
the definition it's
when you're making investment of money
uh relying upon the efforts of others
and expectation of profit it becomes an
investment contract a security
okay the fundamental difference between
bitcoin and ethereum is
ethereum's monetary policy changes every
six months
every few months it changes there's a
difficulty bomb in ethereum that's been
getting pushed back since 2016.
they keep pushing it back when it goes
off it will wipe out obliterate a 50
billion dollar ethereum mining industry
just wipe it out completely change the
protocol flip everything to proof of
stake
they keep putting it off okay that
sounds like a group of people exercising
influence over the protocol
the thing you need to know about bitcoin
is on pizza day
may 22nd 2010
bitcoin is trading for a couple of
pennies for the first time in
15 months or or something like that
the protocol
hadn't changed and has not changed
it when it was a penny the protocols
were all the same
today they're the same exact protocol
there was a war
fought over this the block size war
and the block size war
all of the powerful holders and miners
and exchanges wanted to change
the protocol and double the block size
it would have changed all the economics
of bitcoin forever for the next thousand
years it would have screwed up the
economics of the miners
it would have shifted the balance of
power in favor of of of some holders
versus others
that war was lost the original bitcoin
protocol
continued on and that means it's an
unadulterated uh protocol and it's shown
itself to be resistant to the influence
of of any group of people that's what
makes it property
property is critical because prop
if property makes bitcoin being property
makes it the ethical foundation of the
crypto economy
and by ethical foundation i mean
it's unethical for a public figure to
endorse a security
if you're the mayor of a city the
governor of a state if you're a
politician a congressman a senator
a president of a nation
you can't endorse a security nor can you
make a security underpinning of the
balance sheet
of a public uh a public organization
right it's like i couldn't say i really
think that every citizen of kansas city
should buy twitter stock because it's a
better store of value
it's conflict of interest it's probably
illegal
it probably violates all sorts of
foreign practices acts as well as all
the ethics laws
and so this this is a very bright line
property versus security and as soon as
you start to exercise influence over the
protocol
it becomes a security
if you look at all the cryptos
you know there might be a dozen that you
could debate a property a debate of the
ones that you could debate a property
there's one that's dominant which is
bitcoin
there's 17 000 securities
as the sec
and the regulators move there's going to
be a massive shakeout
if they ever do clarify what the
securities laws are
there's a whole set of disclosures and
obligations and then
and then you're going to see
you know the entire industry rationalize
in a big way what happens if they do
categorize bitcoin as a security well
bitcoin's not a security
right we've already we've already
crossed that chasm the point the real
question you should be asking yourself
is what happens if they categorize
ethereum and every other crypto as a
security you're underestimating the
power of politicians to screw things up
you're underestimating the the power of
them not liking a person like you to get
up and say whatever you want to say
and you offend them you offend
politicians you know people who are yeah
i've just read an article right now from
political can you pull up the political
article it's just the way they i get
that
but the real point here is there's 17
000 cryptos and and all the rest are
much more centralized so yeah but they
know the most powerful one is the one
that you're you're supporting and the
reason it's powerful is because it's
completely decentralized and and no one
nation state can shut it down not even
all of them can shut it down if they
wanted to
so so so you so these uh
sweet amazing nice
kind
uh supportive people who love
uh independent thinkers like you
politicians
you don't think behind closed doors
they're sitting there trying to figure
out a way to regulate or get their hands
on bitcoin because they're starting to
lose a little control with the bitcoin
commission because the bitcoin community
essentially the crypto community forget
you know let's just say bitcoin one side
and a crypto community
i said this the other day i i think it's
becoming a political party i think the
cryptocurrency yeah so regulations
first of all there's like 250 million
people
that are that are pro bitcoin right now
and this is spreading at millions per
week so
you can't find you can't find
any large constituency that's anti right
it's a virus that's spreading right
you're not going to get any votes by
being against bitcoin right there is no
constituency that is anti-bitcoin second
regulations not bad right sometimes
people say oh they're going to regulate
is bad now the truth of the matter is
the faster the regulation comes the
faster the 17 000 other cryptos get
sorted into their buckets as securities
platforms art etc
and that will actually shake out
a lot of the noise in the system result
in a lot of capital focusing upon the
winner which is bitcoin
and it'll also accelerate the entry of
institutional capital into the space
because there's a hundred trillion
dollars worth of money that's not in the
crypto space that's afraid to come into
the space because they're not sure about
the definitions between the securities
that's a valid concern property yeah
that's a valid concern so in fact the
regulation probably would be the best
thing that ever happened i've seen you
say that yeah can i read a quote that
you've actually said yeah um this is on
page four bitcoin evangelist michael
saylor says clear crypto regulations
would speed
institutional adoption so cnbc story
tighter government crypto regulations
would actually be a positive catalyst
for bitcoin microstrategy co-founder
michael saylor says additional regular
regulatory insurance on what the
regulation is well yeah that's what i
want him to to clarify he says
additional regulatory clarity from the
biden administration is going to going
to benefit bitcoin and accelerate
institutional adoption of that asset
stressing
a major bitcoin believer and holder he's
looking for clear bright line
definitions of a digital property
versus a digital security versus a
digital currency and the operating rules
of the digital digital exchange
you know you know you said something you
said there's 250 million people that are
uh pro crypto right or pro bitcoin but
250 million probably more after this
week okay we probably made 200 million
fans i don't disagree but i think
there's that's right i think you're
saying because of ukraine yeah but not
just ukraine canada there's a lot of
different things that's going on but but
here's what i would also say michael
there's
seven and a half billion people in the
world that are pro-freedom
except for the people that are
pro-communism and control you're
underestimating the power don't you
think because we're part of the same
party
under thinking but don't you think we're
underestimating the power of the few
who hate independent thinkers who go
make their money and they're sitting
around you know constantly advancing and
questioning them and
in a way cryptocurrency is a big middle
finger to all the politicians
and they don't want to have 250 million
middle fingers right so how do you
how do you address that part amongst
these few that like to control people
like you it looks like it looks like
bitcoin's winning
if we if we look at what's happening
bitcoin is spreading everywhere in the
world it's only been a few years
right i mean it's it's the most
powerful disruptive force in the decade
you know look at look at the rate at
which it's spreading zero to 250 million
people
and if you turn on cnbc and watch i you
know count the number of minutes that'll
go by before you'll see the bitcoin
ticker flip up on the screen or before
they'll start talking about it
um as far as i can see the idea of
the idea of bitcoin and the idea of
digital property and digital money and
and uh and
digital freedom
is spreading pretty aggressively
very aggressively um i
i don't really so much worry about it
because um
i mean i
i've met with uh a lot of people
including a lot of politicians i think
you might find
one out of 20 that will be trollish
that'll be negative because they think
it gets them attention
but uh if you speak to most people in
private there are they all think it's a
pretty good idea i think i think you
probably find a lot of a lot of
advocates in russia right now a lot of
advocate remember what happened when
when putin or when the when the russian
bank said they were going to ban it then
all of a sudden they reversed their
stance within 24 hours
right you see the same thing happening
in every single other place in the world
um if you look at the senate and
congress there's
the consensus in uh congress right now
is
is very pro-crypto and it's very pro
bitcoin it's not anti if you look at the
administration the administration is
moving forward uh with uh with
guidelines that will be beneficial to
the industry
there is a schism between the
institutions and the entrepreneurs by
the way like for example
if jp morgan can issue a stable coin
then the existing stable coin issuers
would view that as being competitive to
them so there's a lot of tension between
institutions and entrepreneurs and
between states and federal government
but i don't think anybody disagrees with
the idea that uh that bitcoin's here to
stay and this is spreading
there's a
and so i'm not much worried about it but
look
you can choose to be pessimistic and say
oh yeah well somebody somebody somewhere
will take it away because it's too good
an idea but what are you gonna do roll
over and die i don't think it's
pessimism you you started your company
in 89
and you went public in 98 you got a
10 million dollar deal with mcdonald's
in 92
from 1990 to 96 your company grew at 100
every year from getting these facts
right you come from an era where andy
grove was god and andy grove wrote a
book where he ran intel i think they ran
the company at what pace they were
growing he wrote a book called only the
paranoid survive so there's a difference
between pessimism
and paranoia
the paranoia from a few
uh comes from supporting the cause of
crypto nobody's sitting there saying i
mean in so many ways this makes sense
it's tough to argue this who doesn't
want to not be controlled by the bank i
can't think of any time where bank has
been the low income middle income or the
average guy's best friend who's ever
liked the bank i don't think any time
anybody's ever liked the bank the low to
middle income in the rich unless when
the rich was just getting money without
you know what you're talking about it's
being printed i'm just my skepticism is
to be a little bit paranoid about what
these politicians who sit around
uh uh wanting their names to be on a
bill and a law that can regulate to brag
about it that's the only you know
paranoia that exists and the rational
response to that is go educate the world
so if you go to hope.com bitcoin is hope
go to hope.com there's courses and books
and educational materials on bitcoin
if you go to my website sailor.org we've
got a free bitcoin for everybody course
we've given it to
tens of thousands of people
um
why do you think i'm sitting here
talking to you today but i think the
level above that though if i if i was
arrogant and presumptuous i just sit
back and wait for the inevitable to take
place but
i don't think uh i don't think we can
sit back and wait i think we got to go
and speak with every politician every
influencer we got to reach out to every
community
you got to go on television you know go
on cnbc fox cnn you know bloomberg
and educate
look
bitcoin is is the digital transformation
of and we are living through the digital
transformation of property money and
energy
and and once you understand this idea
digital transformation of property money
and energy
you realize that you know the world's
not going to understand that for a
decade i mean it'll take 10 years 15 20
years before people get their hands
around what is that i mean it's so
inconceivable if you go back 100 years
and you look at electricity
how long did it take before people
really understood the concept of
electric energy
can't touch it right without getting
shocked by it but it was a scary thing
by the way it was regulated
right it was regulated and and uh it
took a long time for people to embrace
it and it changed the entire world
the same happened with chemical energy
in the form of standard oil
it was regulated took a long time for
people to appreciate it aviation air
power nuclear power all of these things
you know digital energy is cyber power
bitcoin is cyber power right the next
war will be fought in cyberspace if you
don't master digital energy you're not
going to win it you can't even defend
against it most people haven't even
figured this out right now that uh that
digital energy is critical
but you know like
even i i got a lot of twitter followers
when i post on twitter only about a
third of my followers understand what
digital energy is
right
they don't really get the idea i we have
created a file which we can move at the
speed of light on a layer 2 or layer 3
network on an apple apple pay network or
a whatsapp network or any website
that moves energy in a conservative
fashion through cyberspace
for the first time in human history
that's a profound idea
they don't get it right if i have a
digital music file
and i send it to you and you run it
through your headphones or you run it
through a speaker you can listen to
music
if i take away the computer and i take
away the headphones is it still digital
music
sure it is a digital music file but you
need to actually decode it and run it
through a speaker with electricity for
it to be digital music
that's profound if i have a file as
digital energy and it holds a billion
dollars in it and i send it to you in
tokyo and you run it through that
decoder and then you go and you buy a
billion dollars of electricity
or a billion dollars worth of weapons or
a billion dollars worth of buildings i
have moved digital energy through
cyberspace
i have to decode it
it's a big idea we never did it before
right it's like putting something in
orbit
right everything's ballistic until it
finally hits escape velocity and then it
orbits the earth forever
and orbiting forever in orbit is a
pretty big idea
that's what's going on here it'll take a
while for people to figure it out we got
to educate them so so let's start so
that's uh i like that uh point about
education i think the other part would
be which is one above that is guys got
to get involved in politics and office
they got to get involved there as well i
think some of the guys from the crypto
community have to get involved in
political you know arenas congress
senate governor even some being inspired
to go into
presidency look at the president of el
salvador what kind of an edge he has i
think the strategy for a guy like you
going and talking maybe a part of it is
also inspiring some of these other guys
who want to pursue politics because you
know most of the world when we think
about oh my gosh warren buffett he
doesn't believe in bitcoin oh my gosh
bill gates is against bitcoin peter
schiff says bitcoins going to zero which
i believe you said in 2013 bitcoins
going to zero but you flipped you
started educating and getting a little
bit more clear and then you went to a
different direction even monger recently
said charlie munger said the following
he says i wish
it and this was last week i wish it had
been banned two weeks ago immediately
and i admired the chinese for banning it
can you imagine charlie munger a
capitalist agreeing with china monger
said wednesday a daily journal corp
annual meeting which was held virtually
i certainly didn't invest in crypto i'm
proud of the fact i've avoided it it's
like a venereal disease or something i
just regarded as beneath contempt
the 98 euro billionaire has been long
critic of bitcoin previously calling it
rat poison
and uh i mean he just
certainly the great short squeeze in
gamestop was wretched access certainly
the bitcoin thing is wretched access i
would argue that venture capital is
throwing too much money too fast and
there are considerable wretch access and
venture capital and other forms of
private equity and he just doesn't stop
he keeps going and going and going so
the world looks at these guys the people
who have been influencers in the finance
world for a while
who are totally against it
and then
somebody sits there and says well
i i i trust buffett more than i do
michael
why should i believe these guys that are
talking about bitcoin what you're seeing
is a shockwave moving through the
culture
you're seeing the most disruptive force
in the world right now and it's slamming
into people and institutions faster than
they can
then they can absorb it and and
appreciate it and understand it
and this is like shock waves in the real
world right if i move an airfoil through
the air faster than the speed of sound
the speed of sound is the rate at which
air communicates with itself the air
can't get out of the way i pound into it
i create massive turbulence and noise
the way to solve it is you go slower but
you know then you're not supersonic
you know charlie munger wasn't an
advocate of apple computer right how
about amazon right how about how about
microsoft right
warren buffett's a friend of bill gates
for how many years and he still hasn't
bought microsoft stock and microsoft is
an idea that was
you know
fairly well understood 40 years ago 30
years ago
so um
what you have is is something so
powerful that everyone's being asked to
have an opinion right
presidents
you know the president of russia the
president of most nations states they're
asked to have an opinion every
investor's asked to have an opinion
but what if i told you you couldn't
really understand it without a hundred
hours of time invested
how many people after the age of 40
spend 100 hours studying anything
you know
like once you get to how about age of 65
you don't think of monger buffett gates
these guys spent 100 hours studying
bitcoin aren't you sure they didn't
isn't it obvious
i i would say it's almost certain that
he hasn't spent 10 hours
and so i like i i would say the same
with most macro investors though right
now you know what i would say the same
with a lot of crypto investors the world
is full
okay how many people
i mean i see it because i see in my feed
most people in the crypto space devon
spent a hundred hours studying this
how many people have spent a hundred
hours studying the stock that they hold
in their portfolio true how many people
spend a hundred hours studying facebook
yeah based on what you're saying you
don't need to study
bitcoin just trust you and buy bitcoin
no no he's not saying that he's not
right
but i'm not saying that i'm saying that
i spent a thousand hours before what i'm
saying is you're basically saying look
i've done the research you don't need to
do it yourself just buy bitcoin and hold
it for 100 years have a great day bye
it's basically what you're saying
i'm actually saying that people should
do the research until they get the
conviction necessary to make their own
decision
okay
like at the end of the day this is
property i don't run a i'm not promoting
my own security right promoting an
exchange i'm basically suggesting go
west young man get some land
right it's like go get go go to america
right get some property and make a life
for yourself but you decide whether
you're wanting to do that or not here's
the more important point though it's
every single influential person in the
world is being asked to have an opinion
but they're not spending a hundred hours
on the opinion
if i roll the clock back a hundred years
and i went to every politician and every
rich person in the world in the year
1900 and i asked them what they thought
about electricity what do you think
they'd say right
how about how about airplanes in the
year 1904 what was the opinion then
so
it's not unreasonable
uh
and i don't think we should be spending
a lot of time fixating upon the opinions
of
of
famous and powerful and rich people
about a technology that they have not
chosen to make a focal point of their
interest well especially when they're 98
years old like
i think it has to be a factor i think
the more important point is everybody
thinks for themselves
right so
you wouldn't go to charlie monger and
ask him to pick out stocks in your st
name every winning stock in the past
decade
netflix google
apple
facebook amazon
how many of them were recommended to you
by
any of these people that you're getting
opinions on
none of none of the bitcoin antagonist
or critics would have recommended or did
recommend any of those
stocks right so it's it's kind of a
point it's really just marketing
or sparks that are being sent up because
what happens is these guys in the media
they interview them and they want to
like get a rise out of them so they
actually throw this out there nobody is
asking warren buffett's opinion of
silver or gold right now
because no one's interested in hearing
the answer
here's the next one i want to show you
you and peter shift going back and forth
on twitter
uh did do you have the one in regards to
gold is this the one in regards to gold
uh tyler is this the one
so you're going back okay so also
instead of just posting ill relevant
replies might cook all the way to the
table see what peters have set goal
because he's a big proponent of gold
cios who follow michael sailors asinine
advised to plug their balance sheets
into bitcoin to hedge against they
expect an annual inflation rate of two
percent now down as much as thirty four
percent of their hundred one month uh uh
that's 17 years of expected inflation
losses time to pull the plug michael
saylor responds
with returns
on gold versus bitcoin then he responds
also instead of just posting irrelevant
replies to my tweets why don't you agree
to debate me so far you have turned down
every opportunity to do so it's clear to
me
uh that you're afraid to actually
confront me and defend your ridiculous
views so you
take your cowards way out by the way we
invited him to be on the podcast today
he said get me a private jet and we want
him to be on the zoom and he said he's
not available i'm just letting you know
we don't get typically people saying get
me a private jet that was his request
and then you say it's not clear what we
could debate we would debate your
position appears to be buy some more
gold buy some gold or silver or gold
stocks or government bonds or corporate
bonds or dividend stocks or value stocks
or emerging market stocks or small
company stocks or anything
really just not too much the debate
would be about bitcoin you think it's
digital gold i think it's digital fool's
gold you think everyone who doesn't own
it should buy it i think everyone who
wants it should sell it and the
fundamental point here is
is
you have to give the world a solution to
their problem not just be a critic
if you want to be a critic you can
criticize everything but but what's his
answer if you listen if you listen to
peter's debates what he says is he only
has five percent of his portfolio
invested in gold which means that he has
95 invested in something else but what
is the something else
and the point is he you know you're back
in the same you know hedge fund shuffle
mentality it's like just give me all
your money and i'm just going to shuffle
it with random 95
opacity on random stuff
back and forth but don't question it
what about the five if it was it was a
recommendation he would own more than 50
percent of his portfolio in the gold but
he doesn't believe in it
so but his argument would be his
argument would be i don't recommend
people to buy 50 i recommend people to
buy two to five percent that's his
position he doesn't have an answer to
the
that that means that you're going to
lose 95 of your wealth so what's the
answer so and your point is that
depression by the way i already i have a
debate if you go online and you google
michael saylor gold debate you'll find a
pretty good debate that's got more than
two million views right now where i go
point by point
through the differences between bitcoin
and gold
the issue with with peter is
peter's not offering a solution to the
world
right he's simply
trolling
bitcoin and he's not trolling bitcoin
with any
any real concrete criticism other than
he just doesn't like it right like but
wouldn't the world so mike if you guys
did have a debate
wouldn't the world benefit i guess the
question is i don't realize
he doesn't he doesn't have a concrete
argument but you're not dodging a debate
with him i i don't see the point of
debate when peter buys a billion dollars
worth of gold
then i'll have a debate with him
so you're saying you don't see him as a
true believer even in the he says hey
gold is your hedge against as pat uh uh
properly pointed out to him on the fox
interview that peter and pat had said
listen peter you're selling armageddon
to sell gold yeah and you're saying and
yet peter only owns five peter short
gold peter is a peter is anti-everything
for example he's got more investment in
gold stocks gold miners than gold well
gold miners are short gold gold miners
incentive is to dump as much gold on the
market as possible as fast as possible
if you read the balance sheets of the
gold miners what you'll find is they
don't hold gold as an asset so so gold
miners don't believe gold is money if
they did they wouldn't sell it they'd
buy it
and peter doesn't believe gold is money
if he did he wouldn't allocate 95
percent of his wealth to something other
than it
and ultimately
the fundamental issue with peter is you
know he's just debated you know he's
debated this issue for a
decade all of his argument is just i
don't like bitcoin he hasn't come up
with anything worth refuting that i can
see and if you go online you'll find
three four five six peter shift debates
and he just doesn't say anything other
than just bark the person that he's
debating with so i can't see it's
constructive this is a reasonably
constructive debate if you go to me and
frank gestra where we actually had a lot
of
back and forth
fundamentally though
find me somebody in the world that has
invested more than 50 percent of a
portfolio and gold
or at a billion dollar level
like my my position is pretty clear i've
invested almost four billion dollars in
bitcoin
and i'm not telling you you need to
invest half your portfolio in it i'm
just saying that i think that it is it
is money it is an asset it will
appreciate in value and one can create a
strategy where it is the the dominant uh
part of the strategy
there are other people that have
invested in companies amazon
amazon was jeff bezos strategy i get it
big tech
other people have bought city blocks in
new york city that's a that's a valid
strategy so
investing in property or investing in
technology is a valid strategy but on
the other hand
find me someone that is actually bet
five billion dollars on gold where it
constitutes more than fifty percent of
their portfolio and it's their own money
and peter's not one
peter hasn't bet on gold peter's betting
on gold going down he's buying the
bitcoin the gold miners that are dumping
the gold making the gold price decay so
that doesn't make any sense if you dig
into the gold miner balance sheets
read read the the two three biggest gold
miners what you'll find is
they overmind the gold dump the gold
then they pay an income tax then they've
divided out their excess and pay a
dividend tax then they pay off their
debt which is two percent so another way
to say it is they would rather uh loan
money out to the world for two percent
interest than whole gold
that's how bad they don't like gold
right and they're the ones that mine the
goal it's it's an it's a crippling
indictment of the entire industry
right that they think it's going to zero
that's why they keep dumping the gold on
the market
find me somebody
that really believes in gold in fact
every single gold proponent you'll find
on the internet if you listen to them
they'll start their conversation with
well first of all i don't recommend you
invest more than five or ten percent of
your money in gold it's just like it's a
hedge thing just which makes the gold
miners really no different as a
commercial enterprise than
timber cutting
how are you processing i uh here's how
i'm processing we're one minute over i
want to respect the the time as well as
we got meetings that we got to go to as
well michael this uh we don't have
enough time with you do you you just
talk and you person's got to listen to
how you're processing your uh decisions
this was extremely i hope the audience
enjoyed it as much as i enjoyed it i
feel we needed two or three more hours
together uh uh i'm uh
i'm assuming peter schiff wouldn't mind
sitting next to you for a debate and if
you're up for educating the world maybe
it would be a great educational moment
for the audience if we can get him here
we can't get him in a private gym and we
get him on the greyhound that floats
from puerto rico to here who knows or
get into a private jet in front of a
zoom and then he'll accept it but uh
having said that uh would love you have
to back on michael uh uh thank you again
for taking the time to come out this was
wonderful appreciate you yeah thanks for
having me guys absolutely take care gang
we're not gonna do podcast again this
week because i'll be out of town but we
will do it again next week i think we've
got a very busy week next i got a very
very busy week yes take care guys
bye-bye
you